[Música]
y seguimos con más noticias económicas
en directo américa y como siempre nos
acompaña daniela blandón para esto
daniela bienvenida de regreso y
empecemos con el nuevo plan económico de
la primera ministra británica listos
hola de nuevo maría clara pues la nueva
primera ministra del reino unido dice
que prefiere los recortes de impuestos a
las dádivas pero la magnitud de esta
crisis la ha obligado a actuar de la
siguiente manera según el plan anunciado
hoy gran bretaña congelará las facturas
de energía de los consumidores durante
dos años y brindará apoyo a las empresas
en un paquete que podría costar
alrededor de 172 mil millones de dólares
que serán financiados con más deuda eso
significa que las facturas domésticas
promedio no superarán las 2500 libras al
año por calefacción y electricidad un
paso que se anticipa a un aumento que
iba a haber en octubre y que las iba a
dejar sobre los 4 mil dólares al año el
triple de lo que costaba hace un año
ahora otro de los anuncios es que
aprobará más perforaciones petroleras en
el mar del norte y que levantará la
prohibición del fracking en un intento
por aumentar el suministro de energía
pero promete ser más polémico en su
negativa a imponer gravámenes a las
ganancias extraordinarias originadas en
la guerra por ejemplo para las
petroleras
de dónde viene el dinero preferiría
haber un impuesto sobre las ganancias
inesperadas de las empresas de energía
en lugar de aumentar el endeudamiento
se debería haber hecho más sé que eso
también fue como no tener en cuenta el
impuesto a las ganancias inesperadas de
las compañías petroleras que están
ganando mucho dinero
esta crisis energética ahora está
acabando con todo de 600 libras al mes
estamos pagando 1800 por electricidad y
gas y si sigue así no creo que
sobrevivamos más probablemente otra de
las noticias es que el banco central
europeo subió sus tasas de interés claro
como ya lo esperaba el mercado porque es
la duda no era si la ciudad subir o no
sino cuánto la ciudad subir algunos la
posta van a 0.75 puntos otros a 0,50
finalmente quedó la primera opción que
es la más agresiva para lo que están
acostumbrados los europeos y tampoco
tiene precedentes esas tasas de interés
inclusive estuvieron negativas por algún
tiempo hasta un poco más allá de la
pandemia básicamente cuando ocurre esto
es que los bancos no son los que cobran
por prestar dinero sino que les cobran a
ellos por guardar él de efectivo en
julio de este año se revirtió esa
estrategia quedaron en 0% después de que
la subieran por primera vez en 11 años
para dejarlas en cero y ahora están en
0.75 por ciento y qué efecto tendrá esto
sobre el bolsillo de los europeos pues
mar y aclara la estabilidad de precios
recordemos es el mandato principal del
banco no solamente europeo sino de todos
los bancos centrales y subir las tasas
es el antídoto más utilizado para
combatir la inflación que en este caso
está en récord o muy cerca del 10 por
ciento interanual aunque corre el riesgo
también de empeorar una recesión que se
supone que ya está afectando a europa
tasas más altas lo que hacen es que sea
más costoso pedir prestado consumir
también invertir y eso reduce la demanda
de bienes el problema que es que en este
caso la inflación no proviene de la
demanda no es que haya más gente
demandando sino de la oferta y sobre
esto es muy poco lo que el banco puede
hacer directamente y le doy un ejemplo
la energía no está más cara porque todo
el mundo esté consumiendo más energía
sino porque no hay buena oferta de gas
desde rusia y el precio se ha
multiplicado por 10 y cuáles son los
indicadores de este jueves
street abrió a la baja a la espera de un
discurso que pronunciará el presidente
de la reserva federal ser un power en
busca de pistas sobre qué harán en
adelante para controlar esa inflación de
la que tanto hablamos en europa el euro
se mantuvo por encima de un mínimo de 20
años frente al dólar y los mercados
reaccionan a la baja la subida de tasas
del banco central en un intento pues por
controlar la inflación en reino unido la
libra que alcanzó un mínimo de 37 años
el miércoles de se recupera ligeramente
frente al dólar y las bolsas asiáticas
también se recuperan tienen ganancias
optimistas de que wall street' romperá
esta semana una racha de tres semanas de
pérdidas sólo japón subió más del 2 por
ciento hoy y que cifra tenemos del día
20 7% esto creció el envío de remesas en
guatemala entre enero y agosto de 2022
según el banco central en total a los
familiares que viven en el exterior han
enviado a sus familias más de 11.700
millones de dólares este año las remesas
son muy trascendentales para la economía
de guatemala porque alrededor del 34 por
ciento de sus 18 millones de habitantes
sobreviven justamente con estos envíos
desde el extranjero y la mayoría
proviene de eeuu daniela gracias por
toda la información nos vemos mañana nos
vemos mañana y nosotros seguimos con
directo a parís